My favorite artists,
performers or comedians always tend to be the ones who tipped till the lines of
what we deem acceptable forms of self expression.
These are people that challenged the status quo.
People willing to put themselves on the line,
willing to explore offensive,
introspective,
or just plain messy or dirty topics.
They had the ability to express where we all feel but can't explain.
One of my all time favorite comedians was bill Hicks.
Why that our institutions are failing us.
Uh,
the church,
the state,
everything's failing is because,
um,
there are no longer relevant.
Anyone here advertising,
marketing,
fill your shot.
It's going to be a joke coming.
There's no fucking joke.
Comment.
You are Satan's spawn filling the world with filing garbage your pocket.
You are fucking eyes kill your shelf.
It's the only way to save your fucking soul.
I want my till they're listening to people who's fucking around.
I don't care if they died in their own
with putting a goddamn dollar shine on every fucking thing on this planet.
And tomorrow ladies and gentleman,
there's selling your fucking life out for money.
You.
Don't you ever fucking forget it either.
There's Dick Jokes coming up.
Please.
Your relax.
That's going to happen to the arms industry.
When we realize we're all aligned.
It's going to fuck up the economy.
Today.
Young man on acid realize at all matter is merely energy condensed to a slow
vibration that we are all one consciousness experiencing itself.
Subjectively.
There's no such thing as death.
Life is only a dream and we're the imagination of ourselves.
Here's Tom with the weather,
with on topics.
A few comedians would even think about touching,
and he did so in such a brilliant way.
He had absolutely zero need for approval.
He was able to handle the tension of the audience,
not laughing in a way very few performers could do.
He was able to handle it so well that it was completely willing to alienate
parts of the audience if it meant getting his real point across.
One of the best examples of someone embodying the spirit of Bill Hicks,
challenging our preconception of how we view comedy is the insanely creative,
thoughtful,
and talented musical comedian.
Bo Burnham,
my ex girlfriend,
had a really weird fetish.
Uh,
she used to like to dress up as herself and then act like a fucking bitch all
the time.
Right.
Han's Taylor,
when you do a little bit of thing.
I is a Dutch absurdist.
Uh,
one of the things he does is he brings out a,
a sock puppet,
which is a black sock if you're already,
I don't like them.
All right.
And so it's a white sock.
Yeah.
When did my mother first described gay sex to me?
Good question.
I was eight years old.
She said,
what happens when two men love each other like that?
What they do is they,
uh,
they take off all their clothes,
they get in the bed and they shit on the Bible.
Okay.
Bone never dove into the realms of politics,
war,
corruption or poverty,
like bill head in his own words,
he said
revealing it in yourselves.
I never talk about what I really think about onstage directly cause I just don't
think I don't value what I think at this point.
How about those issues?
We'll just really like,
I don't,
I don't think anyone wants to get up and here at 20 year olds like tell them
what they think we do,
the world,
where would you,
but what Bo was able to do was provoke our thought process on a completely
different level from his first songs that blew up on youtube too is witty one
liners and self deprecating humor.
And I masturbate cause I'm the only one whose standards are low enough to
wait
to his incredibly deep song lyrics.
As he evolved as a performer,
he continued to find new thought provoking ways of getting his message across.
It's a consummation of helping to be wished to die,
just sleep or tends to dream Aye.
There's the rub for in that sleeve of death what dreams may come and we have
shuffled off this mortal coil,
muscular smells like
hit such a hidden cleverness and so many of the songs he performed,
if you weren't paying very close attention,
the deeper meaning would pass right over your head.
Many of his songs showcased a brilliant play on words hit an incredibly unique
use of language.
And I was amazed that I could listen to his songs dozens of times and grasp a
different meaning buried in the seam lyrics.
I had heard so many times before
Bose act and a college audience seem to be a match made in heaven with
astonishingly clever songs like new math
Santa Claus multiplied by I.
Well,
I guess that makes him a real and the square root of the end to Ba is app
songs like nerds and my whole family thinks I'm gay.
Detailing the struggles of growing up seemingly out of the loop of the cool
kids.
Even my boyfriend thinks I'm gay,
another mother fucker.
His earlier songs were very clever and seemed like the creation of an innocent,
eager young man just wanting to put his art out and get noticed.
We saw a change in him when he put out his first non comedic song,
art is dead.
Okay.
How the world,
where would you do me a favor?
Just kind of,
you do me a favor.
Would you do artists,
dad?
Because I think that song says everything that I think I'm talking about.
Hey.
Yeah,
I'll do that one.
Yeah.
He's a prop comic
detailing the harsh truths of how show business really operates as well as his
own emotions.
Not Feeling that he deserves the attention.
He's getting Ben to a birthday party for retail trend,
one of the children and won't stop screening cause he's just a little at 10
Santa tracks or when he grows up to be a comic or acts or he'll be your award in
for never been touring for never understanding or learning every day can't be
about him.
There's other pain.
Must be psychotic.
It must meet the men said,
I think that I'm worthy evolve.
There's a tension of all of this money.
He goes even deeper in the finale to a second special.
What was the song we think we know you.
That's the end of the show.
I probably should have ended it on a sort of higher note there,
but uh,
yeah,
that's the end of what I hope you liked it but oh oh my God.
How are you?
I haven't seen you since like freshman year.
Oh my God.
It starts out with him dealing with what we can assume our various encounters.
He has throughout his life anyway,
a fan with the superficial infatuation with him,
an agent trying to grow the
Bo Burnham brands.
Young people do not respond to this,
you know,
introspective material are these challenges to the form.
You know,
young people want jokes they can relate to.
Okay,
so write a write a silly song about Facebook
and an old classmate telling him fame has changed him.
You've changed.
I never knew you but uh,
my friend's old roommates friends that he knew you in high school and you became
a real ass hole once all this comedy stuff started happening.
What?
What is it man?
You think you're better than us did?
You're better than us just cause
these three separate interactions converge into one main point.
That becomes the theme of the song.
Oh,
we think you've changed bro.
We know best.
We think you've changed bro.
We know best that we think we know you.
We think we know you.
We think we know,
we think we know,
you know,
a seemingly small well one could describe as first world problem.
We know when that is very real and we all seem to face,
people always love to put you in a box.
They live to categorize you.
It just makes things simpler.
It makes their world easier to understand.
After all,
we can't go around thinking about all the infinite complexities hidden deep
within every person we meet.
There is not enough time in the world.
So we fit everyone we know perfectly into a category based on a small amount of
knowledge we have of them.
It was when we're nearing the end of his third special,
make happy that we all experienced one of the most real moments I had ever seen
from a performer.
Could we get the house lights up for a second?
Could you let the lights on stage,
let the artifice fade away.
Now we're all the same.
I mean you're all facing this way
still.
You know,
I look at it,
I look out at you and it's a very diverse crowd.
I mean more European than I would have hoped,
but we'll get there.
I look at the young people,
you know,
and I feel like I was born in 1990 and I was sort of raised in America,
but it was a cult of self expression and I was just talking,
you know,
express myself and have things to say and everyone will care about them.
And I think everyone was taught that and most of us found out no one gives a
shit what we think.
So we flock to performers by the thousands because we're the few that have found
an audience.
And then I'm supposed to get up here and say follow your dreams as if this is a
meritocracy.
It is not okay.
I had a privileged life and I got lucky and I'm unhappy.
Right.
They say it's,
it's like the me generation.
It's not,
it's not the arrogance is taught or it was cultivated.
It's,
it's self conscious.
That's where it,
it's conscious of self with the social media,
it's just the market's answer to a generation that demanded to perform.
So the markets that here perform everything to each other all the time for no
reason.
It's prison,
it's horrific.
It is performer and audience melded together.
What do we want more than just lie on our bed at the end of the day and just
watch our life as a satisfied audience member and I know very little about
anything,
but what I do know is that if you can live your life without an audience,
you should do it.
He's rented in interviews about the VAT badness of a social media culture.
Everyone is creating these curated versions of their own lives that are
impossible to live up to.
As a people.
We demanded a platform to perform so the market gave it to us.
There's no substance.
There's no need to be thoughtful.
There's no need to spend countless hours working in honing a craft,
no need for genuinely expressing yourself to an art form.
You can skip all of that.
Just post your rant on to Facebook.
No one is really listening,
but enough people hit that like button that we get our little bit
dope.
We used to glorify icons and celebrities based on their merits.
Whether or not you liked Jimi Hendrix music,
you could feel the soul of his art oozing out from every poor.
Now we glorify celebrities simply for living their lives.
The work they put out simply isn't good enough yet we don't hold them
accountable to any kind of standard.
Everything has become homogenized.
There's no depth.
Our attention spans had been damaged by 32nd viral videos and clickbait titles.
One of my favorite lines from Terence Mckenna,
a personal hero of mine was when he said,
hi,
where are you?
Are Now
your of your universe?
And if you're worrying about Michael Jackson or Bill Clinton or somebody,
you are disempowered,
you're giving it all away.
I call it icons,
which are maintained by an electronic media.
Okay?
We exist in a culture that says your experience is not valid.
So we didn't outsource our own experience to icons.
We live vicariously through reality TV and celebrity gossip.
We cultivate this curated representation of our lives and put it on display
through social media.
We hope it lives up to the icons we immortalize yet no matter how well we
portray this curated life,
still nobody gives a shit.
Yeah.
We keep trying hopelessly performing in each other day after day.
Oh,
differ and what is real and your brand and your PA,
your high and your arc as your hopes,
your plants,
your ears.
What is real is you and your experience,
but we're told no,
our experiences are irrelevant.
You can.
Since the conflict in boat coming through in his performance,
he had a career that was completely made possible due to social media.
The best part about something like youtube is that everybody has a voice.
The worst part about youtube is that everybody has a voice,
but still people like bone never would've gotten notice in the old form of
media.
His type of performance art is one that could only exist through this platform,
the very platform he's rented against
and rest assured this irony is not lost on him.
He stated in interviews that his entire show was an act of hypocrisy.
He acknowledges how lucky and fortunate he was to find a voice,
an audience to appreciate his work,
but that same medium he used to find his voice,
he now calls prison in horrific
what can be true to ourselves.
One moment is false.
The next our thoughts,
states and emotions aren't a constant state of flux and I think what comes out
of this is an obligation to act through an interpretation of your truth.
Whatever you feel that is in the moment.
Bone knew he had a privileged life yet in this moment right now he was unhappy
with how it all worked out.
That is what was true to him and he spoke about it.
Topics like this can be hard to face yet forced us to do it anyway.
I think we all collectively cringed when he was going down this path.
We didn't want to face it.
Go back to the jokes,
the playfulness,
the silliness.
We said,
I believe that truly revolutionary artists are ones who challenged the form,
who pushed the boundaries of what we find acceptable.
Bo was going to make us deal with this no matter what.
No matter how much we wanted to hide from it.
And now you're thinking,
how the fuck are you going to dig the show out of this weird,
hold on.
Do you want me to be funny and to make a point?
Nah,
Nah.
Batman.
So how do we do it?
Okay.
Both in cracks into his finale to the show entitled can't handle this.
It starts in typical Bobar and fashion.
He lightheartedly makes fun of Kanye West
power.
His $90 tee shirts weren't selling very well.
That was most of it.
And I watched this.
As the music starts to build,
he begins his rant on the width of Pringle cans and Shapolsky overfilling his
burrito.
Yeah.
When it's Europol,
boy
God mot self and Chicken Ball Reno.
No,
I haven't heard this directly from Bo.
Just what I've read out of the mini speculations from fans,
but given how bold presents his shows and his uncanny ability to play on words
and hide meaning in the seeming randomness,
I find it very unlikely that he's not creating a metaphor with these lines.
He keeps repeating.
Yeah.
The line.
I wouldn't have gotten half this shit if I knew what's going to fit in the
Burrito.
All right.
Look,
I wouldn't have got the murder so
water wouldn't have got the peppers.
God,
God damn,
as he's going down the Burrito line,
everything looks amazing.
He wants to add it all to his burrito.
Finally he gets to the end of the line.
He's arrived.
He's made it.
Yeah.
His life and his career are better than he could have ever envisioned and
suddenly everything starts spilling out of the Burrito.
He says,
you should have warned me.
Someone should have told him what would happen if you got into this.
He wouldn't have gotten into half of it if you knew what it really meant.
Good
for all Bo Burnham fans when he spoke the line.
Huh?
Think that I can handle this right now.
Handle this right now.
I don't think that I can handle this right.
I don't think they are not getting handled inside.
I don't think I know the answer.
I just stay here right now,
like comment and watch the skinny kid with a steadily declining mental health
and laugh se tamps to give you what he cannot do if ever,
sir,
I think collectively all of our hearts broke.
How could this person who's been such a source of joy,
laughter and good emotions be unhappy?
It just didn't feel right.
One of our icons,
one of those people we put on a pedestal and glorified,
he is unhappy.
If he is unhappy,
what could this mean for me?
We're not supposed to feel sad at a comedy show.
I came here to laugh,
just make me laugh,
but he didn't care how uncomfortable it made us.
He was going to say,
felt no matter what,
but you don't eat it.
Good night.
I hope you're happy.
Standup comedy and comedy's seems so inherently Western.
So like to understand eastern.
Oh and then and then that might me be me being stupid,
but I like how does that affect your perspective on common?
Cause I don't,
I don't lay down some wisdom.
Wow.
Yeah.
What happened?
That is the correct question.
The answer to that takes a tad of time.
I think the eastern philosophy,
uh,
really,
encouraged is authenticity,
authenticity and nothing but authenticity.
What I saw when I saw you on stage is I didn't see a thing
moment,
but here's where it gets difficult to explain or understand.
I hope that you had gut trembling or something resembling fun.
And if you watch this thing alone,
Robbie didn't laugh,
but maybe a few times you went to sale that of your nose.
But if you hated it,
that's fair buddy.
Either away.
Could you find a little more time for partying questionnaire on a scale from one
to zero?
Are you happy because you're on your own from here.
So are you happy?
I'm open to suggestions.
Are you happy?
But what the fuck kind of question is,
am I happy?
I really want to try that,
get happy,
then I think that I could get it if I didn't always panic every time I'm
unhappy.
I'm a lifer.
I'm always like happy,
which is stupid because I wouldn't need them one it if I got hit,
wait,
Oh God,
my dad was right.
Yeah.
So with,
you know,
whatever,
knew how to be happy on a scale from one to two.
Now are you happy?
You're everything,
you hate it or are you happy?
Hey look,
ma,
I made it.
Are you happy?